think you know a lot about music here's
23 random music facts that'll blow your
mind
Aerosmith's I don't want to miss a thing
was originally written for Celine Dion
Madonna's like a virgin is actually
about a guy getting over a breakup sorry
mr. Brown summer of 69 is about the
sexual position Sarah McLachlan's angel
is about heroin addiction semi Sonics
closing time is not about last call but
rather the birth of the lead singer's
daughter the Goo Goo Dolls slide is
about abortion a boy named Sue was not
written by Johnny Cash but rather shel
silverstein shel wrote a boy named Sue
getting jiggy with it was written by NAS
nothing compares to you and Manic Monday
were both written by prints Cee Lo's
forget you was written by Bruno Mars and
Justin Timberlake's rock your body was
written by Pharrell from Michael
Jackson's final album Alanis
Morissette's you oughta know is
supposedly about full House's Dave
Coulier Gwen Stefani's hollaback girl is
a response to Courtney Love slam of Gwen
in Seventeen magazine okay now pay
attention Britney's toxic was originally
written for Kylie Minogue and slave for
you was originally written for Janet
Jackson TLC passed on baby one more time
while Britney herself passed on Lady
Gaga's telephone and Rihanna's Umbrella
meanwhile Rihanna passed on Miley's we
can't stop but recorded disturbia
instead of Chris Brown did you get all
that pink and Hilary Duff both turned
down Kelly Clarkson's since you've been
gone
Shania Twain and Faith Hill both turned
down Beyonce's irreplaceable Michael
Jackson's bad was originally supposed to
be a duet with Prince and finally Lucy
in the Sky with Diamonds is not about
LSD this is the truth my son came home
with a drawing and set showed me this
strange-looking Woman flying around I
said what is it he said it's Lucy in the
Sky with Diamonds I thought that's
beautiful I immediately wrote a song
about it check the description for
sources and let us know your favorite
music fact
you